steve is with us in Phoenix hi Steve
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks for taking my call Dave sure man
what's up well I got a question or two
here I've got five kids and I've got a
good steady job I'm an accountant and I
was working on step three we got about
five grand worth of savings and we got
the vehicles paid for but what I think
is about they could dump and we just had
an emergency room visit so now I have
$5,000 in debt
so my question is I got about fifteen
thousand and a 401k do I cash in part of
that 401k how much is the emergency fund
okay five grand probably got a thousand
bucks
so you five thousand dollar bill yeah
and your car's got a problem yeah and
you got an emergent and you get
emergency for under $5,000 what's your
household income 50k and what's wrong
with the car well it's we just put about
a thousand bucks into it so but
transmissions getting ready to go so you
know I hate to deplete the emergency
fund completely for the principle of
staying out of debt and then be stuck
with no vehicle now obviously there's a
10% penalty you know cash not the 401k I
would not cash out a 401k unless it was
to avoid bankruptcy or foreclosure and
that's not where you are there's a 10%
penalty pleasure tax rate the government
is going to take half of the money about
40% of it yeah
by the time you could clear the air on
this and so no I would not use the 401k
I'm trying to think through how to work
this have you tried to negotiate with
the medical bill at all oh it was 12 now
it's 5 so they've agreed to accept 5 or
you paid it down to 5 no that's that's
what they've agreed to okay um and do
you guys have you had a garage sale
lately no we did that a few months ago
we moved into an apartment to save money
and you know drop our cost down and you
know we're trying to rebuild our life
here we moved a couple years ago out of
Senatus oh we're we're rebuilding
everything so okay well if they're
offering you a five thousand dollar
settlement on
12,000 dollar bill that sounds like
something we need to try to figure out
what it take but we got to figure out a
way to cover the car too so I don't know
I'm going to try to stretch all of this
out until I can save up another thousand
bucks to fix the transmission and that's
the thing too is I'm taking a look a
hard look okay if they're not going to
charge me interest don't make payments
to the hospital you know what I mean
okay well if you make payments for a few
months at no interest and you know get
this thing squared around where you've
got the money to do both things by
saving up some money you know a thousand
bucks changes this whole discussion yeah
and yeah I'm going to fix that old car
throw a transmission in it and keep
moving and then pay off the bill as soon
as possible and then start rebuilding my
emergency fund and then where you start
and then start rebuilding my car fund to
be able to buy something at that point
but no I I'm gonna do everything I can
to avoid cashing out this 401k the the
problem is is it just it just they just
take you to the cleaners man the
government just takes everything it's
just it's no fun at all